moscú y kiev siguen moviendo sus tropas
en el este de ucrania en una guerra de
desgaste que ya ha alcanzado su día
número 66 las sirenas vuelven a sonar
están sonando en este momento como
pueden oír en mi pro donde nos
encontramos y también si nos fijamos en
los mapas se pueden ver estos avances
que están siendo lentos pero sostenido
de las fuerzas rusas hacia las
localidades más disputadas del donbass
pero también de la ciudad hacia la
ciudad de heart keep que recordemos es
la segunda ciudad más importante del
país así también ha sufrido un ataque un
hospital lo que demuestra que los
centros enteros también siguen siendo
víctimas de esta guerra por otra parte
el mandatario ucraniano loader michelle
es que ha vuelto a insistir en su
voluntad de reunirse con el presidente
ruso vladimir putin a pesar de las
atrocidades el ministro de relaciones
exteriores de rusia en cambio ha dado el
dato actualizado del número de personas
que han sido trasladadas a rusia se
trataría de un millón de personas por
supuesto se trata de una cifra
algunos de ellos han denunciado haber
sido desplazado de una forma forzosa